[Music]
hi
i'm athanasia movenko but everyone just
calls me moon
and today i'd like to talk to you about
how i
made a package and in that process made
some friends
so to know a little bit about me i have
a background in
psychology with a specialization in
neuroimaging
and in this field there's quite a lot of
us who do a lot of coding
but we have no formal training in it so
sharing our code
is kind of scary at least for me it was
completely out of the question
putting my scripts publicly online i
would just
share them with my closest collaborators
and why is it so scary to put your
scripts online well
you have this idea that other people
know what they're doing so when they see
your code they're just going to
think it's like this sloppy mess uh
that is completely useless and they're
just going to throw all these negatives
at you
and in the end the end message will come
that you have no business doing what
you're doing
and it's terrifying
but that kind of changed a little bit
over time
and that started when my colleague doc
approached me and asked me
if we could plot brains in ggplot2 so
i'm obsessed with ggplot2 i plot
everything in it if i can
well i force myself to plot everything
in it no matter what
um so he had this idea
and he kind of just turned around and
made it happen and suddenly we had
brains in gg plot 2.
and it was like this it was such a cool
process to be able to create our stats
and
immediately project them onto areas of
the brain
uh in a way that we would put in a
publication hadn't been able to do that
in r before and i thought
it's not just our labs our lab that
needs this
we have international colleagues that we
know also could use something like this
so
maybe this is a time to figure out how
to share your code
so the doc gave me his script and i
turned the script into a function
and i took that one function turned into
many functions in a package
and i shipped the package off to github
and i was terrified
um excited but
terrified of what people would think
but it turns out i didn't have to be
because people started tweeting about it
like mara started tweeting about it and
other neuroscientists that i respect a
lot
started tweeting about the package being
really good
uh easy to use giving them pretty plots
and suddenly like
all this unequivocally positive feedback
that
i'd never gotten in academia before it
was
so exciting and
thrilling and it was so much fun having
made something that was useful i never
made anything useful before um
and it was just so cool but kind of the
next thing that happened was
even cooler because people started doing
pull requests to our packages
and people we didn't know from before
and they helped us
improve the efficiency of our functions
making sure they
passed our command checks um adding
unit tests i'd never heard of unit tests
sorry
before that pr came and suddenly i was
obsessed about writing unit tests for
everything
um and this user john
shelley from johns hopkins he helped us
prepare our package to be included in
the neural conductor which is like a
bio-conductor for neural neuroimaging
that we didn't even know
existed before this and suddenly we were
connected
to this network of our developers for
neuroimaging
that we didn't know before and we have
this reciprocal
community and it's so extremely cool
and now i'm not so scared about sharing
my code and putting it online i do it
quite often
in my blog and in the multitude of
packages i've made
since that first one um
it's just nice to connect with people
who do and appreciate the
same things you do so make a package and
make some friends